OK.
Let's go next to our caller from the 7 7 4
area code who is calling today from 7 7 4.
A.
It's clear from what's there.
Hey, Cliff, what's up?
Cliff, you're breaking up.
All right, let's let's back it up for a second.
You're breaking up and I'm sorry.
Crazy ambient noise.
So let's see if we can do something about
that.
And I would love to hear your question, Cliff.
Hey, sorry.
Is it better now?
It's drastically better.
OK.
That's great to hear.
So I've been looking at the news.
I heard Bernie just dropped out of the race.
I'm wondering, you know, Cliff, are you communicating
in Morse code?
No, I am not.
OK.
Because for the last 10 seconds, I heard nothing
other than a Morse code like vibration.
Oh, let me read you wondering about Burnaby.
Oh, no.
I will.
Well, actually, it's not a brainer.
I was running with your stances on croquet,
the lawn game.
I'm very much in favor of it.
Oh, my God.
All right, Cliff, we're gonna see you later.
Could you imagine a worse connection than
some of these callers that we have?
I mean, it is.
It's weird.
Isn't everybody at home like how are people
having bad connection?
I guess unless they live somewhere with a
bad connection